good morning John this may have been the
second oddest weekend of my life I
peruse Portland real estate with a
Mythbusters wife on an iPad owned by
Adam Savage yes you can say that my
perception of reality was ravaged but
imagine that wasn't even the weirdest
bit and you're gonna Chuck brick when
you hear the rest of it so sit down and
listen to me rhythmically talk about the
weekends that I participated in
Woodstock our momma blame the hole man I
just want to remember it hearing Adam
Savage saying daddy likes my music and I
better listen to the front oh I wonder
tracks back to back which is probably
why I wrote out the song as a rap but I
hope whoever sits in 19 next doesn't
gags I'm writing down these wheels from
the back of the barf bag for me began
when I landed in Seattle ax to whip up
and then my three I was talking with the
king of dirt hip-hop MC Frontalot as
he's professionally known could probably
cure cancer with his head limb and a
microphone then Molly walked in with her
adorable grin and her boyfriend Chris
and her assistant Kristen two girls one
you don't fear it won't make you become
less you're easily nauseated by things
that normally cute and then I felt like
I was losing control of my brain because
the dumber of the presidents of the USA
was hanging with me making jokes telling
me to be strong like you jumped it out
of my tape player and into my song and
send my friends even to loose walked by
he decides and dives on Xbox Live he's
the guy was a band a hammer on the
largest gaming platform and we were all
brought here by Messrs bobbins one who
were in good form and bought the pizza I
was eating when I learned just how nerdy
was a nerd will week he was adorably
excited
jumpin up and down his mom was the
inverse function of around
take'em dude the 1024 tower I did my
best out of anger for the whole next
hour and then it was on the stage
ostensibly earning my weight the cart
thrown me into overdrive and said engage
my cheeks hurt from the laughing it was
so much freaking from savage traction
front a lot and loading ready run and
then done and we were up there Jake in
our bow like wow the crowd so loud I
could not understand how does it happen
to me I mean I'm just another gig the
last week it had a freaking unique
street just a couple of days ago the
world of planting me trees and now I'm
up in front of a thousand geeks live in
my dreams I'm prepared to accept this as
a pinnacle of my career I don't mind if
it all down
from here because here's a pretty good
list to be downhill from my name there's
an awful lot of Hill there before you
hit the bottom in the morning my
goodness I saw that Wil Wheaton had
pulled out his blackberry and done some
tweaking he tweeted I killed it and from
what he could hear my set of all of
those that we stock got the biggest
cheer I'm not really concerned about
whether this is true or not it just
makes me pretty grateful there's a thing
called Woodstock yeah
[Music]
Woodstock it's a rap that I did about
Woodstock and the beat the beat it the
beat just keeps going with the wind do I
stop I don't have any more words okay
John how is this my life the showing
really well if I do say so myself
everyone who's hilarious the whole time
and my part went well too so I'm putting
a link and my pants down here so that
you can go check it out and there will
also be an imitation at the end of the
video which is just about right now so
John I will see you on Friday and once
you answer some awesome nerdfighter
questions bye bye